[Music]
would you
do
[Music]
[Music]
what's your defense plan foreign
there's no substitute to a quality
firearm for over 135 years Walther has
been one of the world's leading premium
manufacturers of concealed carry defense
pistols and law enforcement firearms
walther's Timeless innovation has once
more achieved a breakthrough never seen
before in Firearms with a new PDP Elite
handgun with revolutionary ergonomics
super terrain slide serrations and a
brand new performance of Duty Trigger
this is the next evolution in
world-class Ingenuity for pistols
whether you are on the job or with the
family it is your duty to stay ready for
any situation that may come quit
Clowning Around visit waltherarms.com to
shop online or use the dealer locator to
find a wallet dealer near you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hmm
delicious glad to be with you now you
used to think green tea was gay
it still is
Brian Green Tea as he watches the show
yes yes that's true yeah we'll get those
names in chats I'm sure later on today
on mug club uh glad to be with you we
have we have a lot to get to today and
by the way there's going to be a more
extended segment on this and Ash
Wednesday next Wednesday with my half
asian lawyer Bill Richmond on the Johnny
Depp uh legal battle that is going on
right now yeah and I want to be clear as
we talk about this today this is an
important moment because of the tie-ins
a lot of people are forgetting the the
metoo movement which spurred some of the
dishonesty from Amber Heard A lot of
people out there don't really know
what's been going on and there's
actually a lot of verifiable evidence
that what the media tried to tell you
was wrong and this really ties into look
I've talked about this as a as a
Christian who really does value and
support the institution of marriage uh
there's a reason though that a lot of
young men don't want to get married now
and there needs to be a decoupling of of
you know marriage in the church and kind
of state laws it can be a tough sell and
uh there really is a point right now
where um the burden of proof is on a man
to prove innocence if he's just accused
of being guilty that's what this trial
is about it really is about rights it's
about men's rights and it's about by the
way real victims and by that I mean both
female victims of domestic abuse and
male victims of domestic abuse and the
current legal system the ram it's it's
it's absolutely horrifying I mean there
are little this is the thing when
Christians are really mad about same-sex
marriage and I understand it I believe
you know marriage is between a man and a
woman there are also little little
chinks in the armor that have been
taking place that have been slowly
eroding the institution by just making
it such a no-win scenario in a high risk
scenario
that you're gonna you're going to see a
country where fewer people are going to
get married and a big part of it is what
we're seeing here today in the Johnny
Depp story so we'll talk about that also
they're teaching pornography in high
schools really some peop you'll you'll
see the clip oh my gosh the guy in a
high schooler there's a guy who is
thrilled about it he looks exactly how
you would expect right that course
filled up fast yes it did
and the ratio it's almost like China the
male to female ratio it does not yeah
it's just all Engineers so uh before my
question of the day this is an important
one and we're going we're now having
competitions for the best comment we'll
be pinned and you'll win some signed
merch and also uh DNA scraping of Gerald
so you can leave it any crime scene you
wish the question of the day it's in
your contract shut up uh how do you
balance your especially as a man how do
you balance your desire for marriage uh
finding a life partner
versus the legal system that is um you
know stacked against you and and women
because a lot of women now are seeing
that men don't want to get married we've
talked about this in the show but we'll
get into the statistics today what kind
of changes do you want to see genuinely
what kind of changes do people want to
see to the institution of marriage to
bring it back to what it was originally
intended to be as opposed to fighting
over stuff and false accusations and
ugliness because that's not what it is
supposed to be and I hate that that's
what it is we'll talk about all that I
really want to hear from you and that
helps with the YouTube algorithm and of
course uh they won't be happy to hear
reasonable responses from you guys but
first Gerald a is here how are you I am
doing well though now I'm going to be
convicted of crimes apparently yes so
yeah how many scrapings are we talking
here well you don't need much no I just
I'm saying how many crimes I don't know
but uh you're going to be on the next
making a murderer at least three are you
saying Geralds at the scene yeah
[Music]
you're gonna have your uh your little
your new one any moment so Gerald B is
going to be back in that chair no no no
no no Gerald B is dead I killed him no
we resurrected him we patched him up and
put a bike patch on him do you know him
you love him you can follow him at
Landau Dave on Twitter and he's actually
going to be uh solo uh this weekend in
Virginia Beach on Saturday Virginia
Beach Virginia you can go to live
withcutter.com tour to see all these
dates Dave Landau how are you sir good
Ahoy how are you I'm fine I'm fine a
little a little aggravated about the uh
Johnny Depp Amber Heard thing yeah it's
pretty crazy yeah I think it's I think
it's because his it's his jewelry yeah I
know like he's got friendship bracelets
and skull rings like he just won a bunch
of ski ball tickets yes that's the
problem yeah so you just came from a
Mardi Gras party right and he is now in
it's like hot seat you don't want the
basketball hoop that goes on your door
Chinese finger trap yes but I do like
Johnny Depp but I think it I think it's
interesting the question that you posed
I think it should be about love and not
about uh stuff yeah and that's what it's
become yep unfortunately and it's too
easy to fake say well I'm doing this for
love great but in a court of law it's
now about stuff yeah you're right though
it does make it very easy to fake it's a
tough tough place to be but uh I agree
with you I also don't like that Johnny
Depp who's from Kentucky fakes a light
Cockney accent yeah I don't know what it
is with uh yeah him and Madonna you
tried to start a physical fight man hey
what are you talking about you know it's
just it's uh the horror I was living
with for so many years what you're from
Kentucky right you're still in you're
from Louisville I went to I would like
to play guitar and I didn't really want
to be an actor and I've done like 80
roles and I don't know what my own
voices anymore and all the time when I
do gay rules it's uh you know I I
suppose it's
uh I have to do it in a manner that's
homosexual yes at least why does Willy
Wonka have to be gay I don't know I went
to dinner with Marilyn Manson so quick
why not
So speaking of horrible things in the
Chocolate Factory yeah the bulk of this
is going to be uh about Johnny Depp and
Amber Heard and it would also amaze me
is the media the media right now we have
an article from variety only a day or
two ago they're still trying to feed you
the me too and privileged white male
when this is an exact example it's
precisely the example of the opposite
yeah and we need that pendulum to swing
the other way and by that I mean swing
toward truth not just recognizing
victims by classes but what is true and
there's a lot that we know is true
that's not necessarily what this case is
about uh first it shows how easily that
can be thrown onto the public and used
against you just by being the white male
by being that's the thing I never
thought of myself as a I suppose white
male but Pirate's not a person
assumption I think just stop just stop
just speak normally come on and get your
tooth fixed I mean you're a billionaire
I know what is that you have the money
that's part of his look so while we're
talking about there's something
horrifying a pair uh well according to
this pair of completely stable uh-huh
well-adjusted young adults uh these drag
queens want you to know and by the way
hopefully it's not like you know Libs of
tick tock where people say that we're
we're doxing people by posting their
public video in which they encourage
people to share it uh they want you to
know that um everyone should be more
like them Zees oh baby how many times do
we have to answer this question foreign
should get off the library steps please
um they're being loud
hey feminists where are you with the
perpetuation of negative female
stereotypes this is one of those things
right if if a woman were to be ultra you
know dressed like a Bratz doll this is
an unrealistic standard for women but
when you have two guys doing it like we
are amazing oh yeah that's incredible
you're you're a walking stereotype of
Barbie now the Barbie doll we have to
make fat and disgusting for young girls
but when you do it this is you are all
the Splendor that is woman
yes
those are the shoes you're wearing are
meant to make a woman taller you're now
you're now six five yeah well you're
shooting for the NBA you couldn't find
any red winged steel toes yes because
when I look at them I'm like yeah
they're living their best life yes oh
it's just reminding me how much I hated
tank girl yes
and white girls
White Chicks White Chicks there you go
yeah people are thinking I'm saying
white girls the film white films
terrible film The Awful film White
Chicks but hey I know I'm confused with
a great film don't be a menace do you
think that they actually believe we want
to be more like them or is that just
what psychologists call projecting
that's what psychologists call for you
okay I think it's definitely projection
and also there it wouldn't being gay is
not enough apparently yes yes
everybody's doing that so we got to do
the next thing just when you thought it
was safe to go back to the library oh
that's when your dad's just going could
you just could you just be gay yeah can
you just be gay I would totally love it
if you just love dudes it's fine I
didn't I didn't even mind that why do
you have to keep doubling down and
ruining Christmas you come every year
dressed as that by the way stop wearing
the ornaments yeah
naughty Santa can only be done so many
times I gotta buy a new tinsel every
year so you got to make hair the next
one they're wearing one of those
rotating Christmas carousels what is
that a Christmas ornament no this is uh
this is a Prada that's a Christmas
ornament that you got from Michael's
yeah where are the two giant bulbs oh
God
all right here's another one to while
we're talking about uh all of these
issues where it is amazing that we are
at this point in society and this is why
there's the rejection of it we talked
about this yesterday culturally some
some big wins that you're seeing with
Netflix that you're seeing with Disney
so this is what uh big Tech big media
wants you to believe is normal and most
Americans are sitting home going what
really you're doing that so Rudy
Giuliani mayor of New York Times Man of
the Year America's mayor yeah America's
mayor guy who single-handedly cleaned up
New York City it was a crap hole and
then all the hipsters bitched about like
I used to like New York when it was grit
you mean you liked being raped yeah you
liked bump his good news it's back yep
everything old is new again yes
so Rudy Giuliani uh was revealed on The
Masked Singer and uh that finally aired
we talked about it but it aired last
night making headlines and then there's
obviously a reaction we need to get to
but here's the big reveal
oh
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
oh my goodness former associate Attorney
General
foreign
so hear the crowd the crowd is cheering
the crowd's having a good time
wow
[Applause]
wow this is definitely something I never
would have guessed you're not gonna be
really surprised when the next box just
opens up it's Hunter's laptop
he should just come out holding it right
so here's the thing is he's saying
um uh Ken uh Ken Jeong is that how it's
pronounced Ken Jong Dr Zhang Dr Zhang
was upset so you hear the audience and
this he he walked off and this what
bothers me there's so many things that
bother me we'll talk about that he's a
comedian
Yeah well yeah he's a comedian also um
isn't he the dude from The Hangover that
plays the grossest stereotype of an
Asian that's a good point but first
let's see his uh righteous indignation
walking off
before I met you and I'm done I'll break
a thousand more baby before I am through
[Music]
time done talk is there any more perfect
example of virtue signaling I cannot be
involved with this program for which I
am paid an obscene amount of money to do
very little work uh because there's a
man with a different opinion yeah here
here's a script where you jump out of a
trunk and show everyone you're micro
penis yeah oh I'm in yeah I'm in it's
fine can I sign up for part two yeah oh
there's three of them great right yeah
and the third one ended up being some
they tried to go like Oceans 11 like
Thriller with it like what is this yeah
it wasn't even a comedy no it wasn't
even a comedy but he also you know the
reasoning was oh he has someone who's
had to face anti-asian discrimination uh
because of Donald Trump and Rudy
Giuliani was he walking off on every
black guy appeared yeah well that would
be weird well if if he's for the
anti-asian crime he probably would like
Rudy Giuliani no no he's against the
anti he's saying that he was a victim of
it that's what I mean wouldn't you like
Rudy when it was in check that's that's
a good point things up yes I love how
people still blame Donald Trump for
things that were happening already in
record numbers before Donald Trump yeah
over 85 of all physical assaults in the
Bastion of conservatism that is the Bay
Area San Francisco uh take place black
people against Asian people if it was de
Blasio I can see him getting angry right
yes or Cuomo something like that yeah
right you could you would walk off for
Cuomo Bloomberg yeah sure Berg there you
go I wouldn't walk off for any of them
no no no why would you used his logic
yeah if I use but but he doesn't use a
lot that's what we should do we should
find some of the other masked singers
who really had like a bad background
that he didn't walk off for and were
like oh yeah you're good with you know
pedophilia or something I don't know if
that's a you know a true story or not
but you know I figure it's not let's be
careful it's not I'm just saying
you know like pick your thing you know
Jared on there like what did he do he
just waited in the wings and I was like
okay is this enough time for me to earn
the street cred like you just go to the
green room and he's like I'm just gonna
eat Cheetos or something actually no he
would go back there and be like do I
have any wonton oh that's just I'm
getting in character for my next film
yeah the next he was just offended by
the song choice I think because Giuliani
had been out for a little bit already
right like obviously big reveal they
talked to him for a minute and then he
sings a song off it's the disconnects
between the audience yeah and him that's
what we're seeing right now and there's
there's value in that and then they
[ __ ] about why people aren't watching
the Oscars they [ __ ] about why people
aren't going to the movies they [ __ ]
about Netflix stock diving about Disney
it's all your fault it used to be that
there were differing opinions between
mainstream Americans and by that I mean
everyone in the United States including
people who are classical liberals and
Hollywood it was just a different
opinion now they despise you they hate
you this is someone walking out on what
was once the world's most popular mayor
yeah who by the way a moderate
Republican people don't remember he was
he was a pro-choice Republican like you
certainly wouldn't have been considered
a hard line right Republican but because
he had the gall to uh be involved with
questioning the election and uh by the
way also broke a story that would have
changed the outcome of the election the
hunter Biden laptop it showed up on this
show for the first time because he has
because he had the nerve he had the
nerve to do that they walk off
oh and correct me was that was that
story proven correct
I I cannot fully substance no that's
right it was fully substantial oh that's
yes 100 right and there was more than
one there were three yeah Ah that's
right remember when they tried to frame
him also for uh yeah with the girl yeah
yeah yeah yeah but he has hair dye so
that makes you know Batman yeah exactly
you know badminton 70s right yeah who
would think that I know it's almost it's
not like every single actor has hair dye
yeah you ever watch me like oh wait he's
55 and he has a full head of black hair
an Italian with hair dye in their 70s
yeah nah have you seen Tim McGraw in
1883
yeah it looks like Pella lugosi's
forehead on his beard yeah they really
just shouldn't have done that no it's
too much
all right so uh here let's move on to
the bulk of of today's show because a
lot of people have been watching this
trial and look it's not just about if
this isn't about celebrity gossip this
is about the state of marriage in this
country and it's about the state of
media and we're now seeing the chickens
come home to roost with me too and it's
it's very rare that you see someone
fight back and you know what I think we
need to see a rebalancing of power I
think real victims of abuse for example
real women who are raped it's very hard
I would like to see more women who are
raped come forward as soon as they can
and use the rape kits now I don't want
something to tell you I want to see more
women be raped no I said I want to see
more women who are raped come forward
and get Justice and get Justice yeah I
want to see more men who are falsely
accused come forward and prove that it's
false and I want to see a legal system
that values yeah values the innocence of
both
and you can't have that you can't have
truth if you're simply seeking social
justice it's like science if you're
starting off with if you're starting off
with a bias you're starting off with
something you're trying to prove one
hypothesis and ignoring the other tests
that are going on well look you're going
to end up with something that may not be
accurate it may not show the full scope
of of the study of of the sort of the
meta-analysis it's the same thing if
you're just Seeking Justice for a
marginalized class you're going to
ignore some key truths and even today
the media uh two days ago but even today
if you search you can still find this
they tried to paint this as a white male
privilege issue so uh this is from
variety
and it says the latest Act and the very
public unraveling of Johnny Depp began
last week in a courtroom in Northern
Virginia pulling back the curtain on the
secretive world of celebrity enablers
and Hangers On and uh goes on to talk
about the white you know being a white
male and the privilege and and there are
still places right now that say that
he's a wife beat or Johnny Depp now yeah
they're still trying to push that
narrative which is amazing yeah because
it's the believe all women thing and not
the you know there's nothing wrong with
uh listening to an accusation and
looking into it yeah but seriously it is
it is innocent until proven guilty for a
reason well you just described what our
court system used to be ah yeah it used
to be of course well now that it's
Twitter it doesn't matter believe all
women why yeah what why have you met
some women yeah no don't believe all
whatever you if you start a sentence
with believe all no stop there don't
believe all believe all insert anything
here yeah that's a bad idea Superstar
drag queens I would probably believe him
less no no can't do that politicians
some of them said they're women they're
not even women yeah I don't even know
how it twivel I mean they are but
they're not I mean they're not I mean
they're not but they are because we
don't want to be removed from YouTube
right right they're women I'm so lost
moving on
so uh let me just lay the stage for you
uh there is no actual evidence that
Johnny Depp committed physical abuse uh
I can't say that he didn't but there's
no evidence that's been brought forward
that Johnny Depp committed physical
abuse against Amber Heard okay uh there
is plenty of evidence that Amber Heard
committed not only physical abuse but
serious emotional and psychological
abuse against Johnny Depp these things
are not in question a lot of people try
and say there was a lawsuit in 2020.
that was a lawsuit between Johnny Depp
and a a news publication not Amber Heard
and that's a very difficult bar to clear
we're going to do a legal analysis with
the half asian lawyer Bill Richmond next
week so I don't want to get into that
today as far as defamation to prove but
today what we want to talk about is the
truth and how this reflects in the
current state of marriage and honestly
men's rights men's rights
it should just be right but
unfortunately now people have said
women's rights and then if you say men's
rights they go oh yeah like you have it
so hard well you know what I don't like
Johnny Depp and I feel bad for the guy
there are a lot of guys out there who
have a get a really really Raw Deal okay
yeah and Johnny Depp also has a daughter
yes and she has an opinion on it too and
has seen stuff inside stuff as well so
you know she's a woman too so has every
woman who's met Amber Heard ever yes and
not surprised at all none of them are
surprised now
sometimes you tend to look past the
garbage because somebody's gorgeous yes
exactly and you're like I think I can
deal with yeah you're like you can yeah
you can't trust me you're putting the
crazy before the horse you never want to
do it now uh what we have the first clip
is uh we're gonna go through some
evidence here and uh video evidence but
the first clip is uh you know so far
Johnny Depp's testimony has been pretty
shocking and uh this one is uh about
something specific that you may not have
known she she pooped in his bed what was
the photograph of Mr death
it was a it was a
it was a photograph of the bed our bed
um and on
my side is for the bed
um
was human fecal matter
she was sitting on one side of the couch
that's when she was trying to explain
DVD of Mordecai a few things about
Coachella
than the fecal nature
delivery
vehicle delivery saying that it was the
dogs
and I I could sorry I could not agree
with her I'd lived with those dogs I
picked up their fun
it was not
the dogs
oh my gosh can I just say okay look I
don't think he's lying when he says that
stuff but he's performing well it's just
he's also weird the way yeah he's very
very strange like if I asked you like
what was on the bed yeah she took a dump
on my side of the bed urana yeah you
know that's also why I love black people
because they're just straightforward
like [ __ ]
that's what would happen but he has to
sit here well you know she uh she made a
long pause made her grumpy and
fecal delivery so here's the thing too
context matters context really matters
she did admit to this just to be clear
and she said it was a prank it was a
prank after you abused him and you were
leaving him and his mother was sick no
no you don't that's not a prank a prank
is something you pull on a friend yeah
it's not something you do to your
husband it's not someone something you
do and you don't pull a prank when
you're in a fight and you just hit him
why do you think it's so so it's not a
friend prank no no I'd be like Joe did
you [ __ ] in my bed it's so funny well by
the way at the time it was still her bed
as well right yeah just not her side
well they had like 25 minutes did she
throw it in or did she just squat I
don't know I just wonder how it got
there if she just full on was like I'm
just it's also disgusting that a woman
could do that not only on command but
angrily yeah angry poop is a is an
uncomfortable yeah yeah if you imagine
punching somebody and being like I'm
gonna go poop in your bed now you know
she wouldn't eat Mexican food beforehand
too he didn't need he didn't need to put
my bed you already punched me why you're
you already stood up for yourself you
already stood up for yourself name that
movie line comment below all right
the punch was gonna be the worst part of
your day I thought it's the worst part
was going to be the punch but really it
it was the poop the poop don't fit you
must acquit I have many pictures of my
dog's poop yes
she's another kind of dog I suppose
they both poop Everybody Poops that's
not the voice is offensive it's not lost
on me it's more so where she pooped 20
feet that way would have been better
the dog wouldn't poop in the bed at
first I was confused because and I
wasn't sure because of the shock but I
thought I remembered it we had a toilet
all right so let me give you the
timeline
after less than a year of marriage heard
Amber Heard was when he filed for
divorce okay she claimed that Johnny
Depp was physically abusive and he
denied the claims at the time okay
there's a divorce settlement reached out
of court just so you know before we get
to more Clips she received seven million
dollars for doing nothing
oh yeah that was that was yeah you were
clearly worth it for the rum diaries oh
my goodness she pledged to donate that
money to the ACLU in the Los Angeles
Children's Hospital uh no records show
that she has doesn't mean that she won't
eventually
make a wish yeah make an nft she left
dumps on the sick children's beds it was
horrible there was a child was progeria
[Laughter]
the boy was blind and said he wasn't
sure it was her but she did say I
remember hurt and I'm pooping on your
bed almost like she got some kind of
sick joy out of it again just never
forget the smell never heard pooper so
um
yes so then they said a lot of Court
just to be clear so she came with these
accusations he denied it boom settle out
of court okay that's how the system is
supposed to work that's the legal system
you have a case of abuse you bring It
Forward she obviously didn't believe
that she had a case for abuse settled
money
given got it then December 2018 she
wrote a piece for the Washington Post
Now we move to the court of public
opinion okay and she wrote a piece
titled I spoke up against sexual
violence and faced our culture's wrath
that has to change and uh her lawyers
are claiming that she never mentioned
Depp in the article it's very clear that
that's what implied is implied and in
subsequent comments and interviews she
also inferred it again this is what the
current 50 million dollar defamation
lawsuit is about okay it's about that
because then Johnny Depp was dropped
from some very significant roles namely
Captain Jack Sparrow yeah by the way she
said uh two years ago I became a the
figurehead for this abuse and I'm like
oh were you married to someone else who
beat you two years ago two years ago I
became a public figure representing
domestic abuse and I felt the full force
of our culture's wrath for women who
speak out here you go look this is why
and this is a thing
gosh this is a real problem yeah it's a
problem that we had with with with rape
you know I talked about this with Elena
Dunham situation and we did our due
diligence where we found the person who
she claimed had written it wasn't true
yeah look when you lead with I found out
what it's like for victims guess what
you've now tart and feathered all real
victims because you're not you're lying
and so because you're one of the most
public figures who gets caught lying it
makes people less likely to believe
people who are actual victims this is
the problem it's not consequence free
it's not consequence free just beyond
you're a crappy person because you lie
and you poop it's the consequences hurt
other women who are actual victims of
domestic violence not to mention the men
who are victims of domestic violence
which occurs far more commonly and we'll
get to that well and I know this might
be controversial but I don't believe
that you have the right to go out and
say Obviously there are laws against
this right and that's why he's suing her
but the damage is already done you
cannot unring the Bell even if Johnny
Depp wins this trial Amber Heard went
out and for years he is seen as an
abuser yeah I understand when when
somebody is is claiming rape you don't
want to disincentivize them right to do
that and say oh well you can't go up I'm
just saying like I I can't do the same I
can't go out and say no I didn't the you
raped me or the you abused me comment is
the thing that is going to be put in
every single newspaper I'm never going
to be able to get ahead of that ever
even if it's totally a lie especially
now Kavanaugh I mean for all to see and
people still use it well that's what I
mean even if it's even if he is innocent
which I believe that he is for the rest
of time he's now a wife feeder and a
rape is to a certain group of people in
the country yeah because once you're
that you're always that well don't you
as a journalist aren't you supposed to
have to substantiate your stories before
you publish them and it seems like in
this case no the one time where it's
like no we can you can just have
somebody come out and say the one thing
well not the one all times yeah a lot of
CNN daily but seriously you you have to
go out and get what two or three
confirmations a lot of times is what
journalists are supposed to I mean back
in the day I guess when Jordan yeah
family right yeah exactly just do that
they don't even do that with this they
just let this article go out and they're
saying No this is totally fine and it
already there was already a settlement
that's the problem there's a settlement
in court in Washington Post goes well we
don't care we're just gonna we're just
going to uh we're just gonna you know
run this and uh ruin someone's life
forever this is the problem there's a
decoupling of actual evidence and a uh
either a trial or our legal system
innocent until proven guilty versus a
second system of justice which is the
the court of public opinion and that's
when people say cancel cultures well you
can say whatever you want but there are
consequences just no no no it's like
saying hey you can go and you can go eat
lunch wherever you want but the bully is
going to take your money and punch you
in the face it's like well then then I'm
not free to I'm not free to so let's get
to some of the evidence here that you
may not have known and actually it would
help if you comment below which parts of
these that we're about to present did
you know versus hearing it here for the
first time because a lot of people who I
had spoken with hadn't heard this before
and now this is the result of Johnny
Depp's testimony but this information
had been out there so leaked audio shows
first off let's kind of hit you with
Fact one that I think is important that
uh she was she was mocking Johnny Depp
saying that no one would believe him if
he came forward as a victim of domestic
abuse this is the recording you can
please tell people that it was a fair
fight and see what the joke see what the
jury and judge think tell the world
Johnny tell them Johnny Depp I joined up
man I'm I'm a victim of Jurassic Barnes
and I you know it's a fair fight it
seems how many people believe or besides
of you
yeah and special thanks to I think
incredibly average uh YouTube is Herb YT
is a channel that posted that kind of
broke it so here's the thing that sounds
well you know what it's just he said she
said only and this is another factor I
guess number two I'll label them for you
uh facts number two it's not he said she
said it's she said she said in the audio
that she hit Johnny Depp here you go
talking about and I watched July and
then I didn't punch you by the way you
I'm sorry that I didn't uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but I
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched don't tell me to
be punched
a long time I've been punched a lot
you didn't get punched you got hit I'm
sorry I hit you like this but I did not
punch the rolls yeah Q I was hitting you
I don't know what the promotion of my
actual hand was but you're fine I did
not hurt you I did not punch you I was
hitting you what am I supposed to do do
this I'm not sitting here am I you are
that's the difference between me and you
baby yeah
I did start a physical fight because
yes you did you did the right thing the
big thing the you know what you are
admirable this is the problem with look
look this is not meant for all women so
please don't get upset I'm speaking in
generalizations here about women like
Amber Heard and there are more of them
out there than many people like to admit
and there are also more men out there
like I don't know take your pick Michael
Vicks than many people care to admit but
this is something that happens a lot and
this is a form of mental abuse of
emotional abuse that occurs toward men
quite a bit beyond the fact that
physical abuse occurs against men in
domestic relationships more often than
the other way around something you
probably didn't know what she does is I
didn't hit I didn't hit you I didn't
punch you the right way I hit you this
and then what they do is they
emotionally abuse someone say oh you're
such a you're such a wimp oh I can't
believe you're complaining about this
you think she might be a baby if Johnny
Depp hit her closed fist or not
do you think do you think she'd be safe
do you think she'd be saying I'm not I'm
not a baby and wipe it or do you think
she'd go
on me think about that for a second
she's trying to say you're weak you're a
she calls him a [ __ ] because you're
complaining about being hit if a man hit
a woman if a man shoved a woman and then
said don't be a bait and that's in a
recording that man would be seen as a
monster and rightfully so but this also
is really difficult for men women need
to understand this guess what no matter
how she hit him
if she were meant she'd be hit back
that's why there's less domestic abuse
in gay couples yeah because both have
nukes
so oh yeah engages fight oh yeah it's
just fists so they're few and far
between because I'm glad we got that out
of our system let's go have sex with 15
guys right
but this is what happens this out of our
system imagine a conversation with a guy
guys can't compute it where it's like oh
so I hit you I punch you stop being a
baby they wouldn't get to the phrase
stop being uh but before they got
punched back that's how it works Amber
Heard hit Johnny Depp
she deserves to feel the brunt of Johnny
Depp defending himself which he didn't
do like any man would and because he
doesn't what's your choice defend
yourself in which case you lose your
domestic abuser or a woman who keeps
coming and coming and coming not only
emotionally psychologically but
physically and then you're a weakling it
is a no-win situation and that is why it
is a an effective form of mental abuse
that women administer toward men it
happens a lot yeah and he was trying to
remove himself from the situation he's
like oh you did the right thing don't
tell me what it feels like to be
punished I know I I have never heard of
sentence like this before I didn't punch
you I was too busy hitting you yeah like
what oh yeah I'm sorry I didn't slap you
correctly I was hitting you so you were
punching me and not slapping me so I
just this is semantic I go to the body
right yeah
I was roundhouse kicking you right so uh
you see your face break though because
she knows that you know she's lost the
most important currency which is her
victimhood right that's a good point and
it also gets worse we'll bring one up
where she actually faked being uh hit so
would you just hit the mic hit the mic
like don't tell me what it feels like to
hit the microphone I just I just Amber
hurted my mic so uh there's also an
Evidence and testimony here present at
the trial
um that Beyond being punched a very
serious finger-cut injury that required
surgery that Depp suffered we all knew
about this I think the initial stories
remember that he got drunk and broke a
bottle the media remember the media
reporting this yeah uh what actually
happened is Amber Heard through a handle
of vodka Adam here you go
was leaning like this in the chair
looking at her first bottle went
then got the other bottle shot
takes the second bottle which was the
larger one
I'm in this position again
and my my hand is on the edge of the
the bar like like that and leaning over
the fingers
like that and uh
she threw the large bottle
and it made contact
and shattered
everywhere
and uh by the way just please don't let
this be a reason for uh liquor companies
to cheap out and start putting in
plastic bottles I hate that keep using
glass oh yeah don't let Amber spoil it
for the rest of us no no papa wouldn't
have done the trick but still no uh and
in case you think he's overplaying it
here and he's oh a baby I warn you for
people who are squeamish here's a
picture of the aftermath oh even blurted
it it was a little too rough because you
know it's I mean it was down to the bone
and he got uh he got MRSA he got staph
infection which you guys know I had in
my foot and uh it can I mean that that
can you can lose a foot you can lose an
arm jeez so um
here we have she clearly physically
abused Johnny Depp these facts aren't
really in question what's in question is
whether the reputational damages are
enough to Warrant him suing her uh there
really is no evidence to the contrary
and we'll wait for the rest of the
hearing but nothing as compelling as
this certainly no admission
in a recording of Johnny Depp hitting
her yeah right I was punching you in the
face not slapping yeah and by the way
she admitted that she did punch him too
as well to a physician and he admitted
to a physician that he was punched in
the face just to be clear he did people
said why would you lie to Johnny Depp to
other people where he said I uh I got
caught in an accordion door but then he
told the physician this is what actually
happened because he was embarrassed yeah
probably embarrassed because you know
he's been so psychologically abused that
he doesn't want people to see him as a
as a weak victim she wants to Champion
herself as a victim and the man is
afraid because guess what they're
condemned if they're an actual victim
fake victim prays as a woman actual
victim as a man condemned that's a bad
place to be it's a bad thing for both
men and women in society this is bad for
everybody yeah when you don't want to
talk about that the issues you have at
home and and that you something's going
on like that there's of course there's a
reason why he only told the doctor it
makes perfect but he told the doctor and
she told a doctor well and it takes
basically Satan incarnate Jada Smith for
us to see like this kind of abuse can
actually be going on and you see
somebody like Will Smith do something
that is just absolutely crazy and you're
like what in the world but if Will Smith
had just been acting out in this Jada
stuff like her videos hadn't been
released and all this stuff but we now
know about her we'll be like ah will
what's going on man it's falling off the
deep end man yeah come on like but now
we go oh because he slept with every she
slept with everybody in Los Angeles and
broadcast it like ah it makes sense you
might be a little she is just grumpy is
there to make sure that he knows he's
garbage every time he has something
positive going for him right I think I
was there it was Oscar night and that's
what she did to him yeah he's like you
better get up there and say you should
go hit a man oh that makes perfect sense
you should go hit a man to defend the
honor of the woman who [ __ ] around
with everyone but you who has no honor
and has been using ridiculous hair dye
in her hair for 20 years and can't
figure out why it's falling out
it's a mystery yeah it's it's it's not
it's alopecia no it's not it's the
turpentine yeah it's the nonsense you've
been putting in your head what is this
paint face I'm a [ __ ] man so uh here we
go so fake abuse uh sorry actual abuse
that had taken place uh we just heard
now Amber Heard went as far as to um
physically fake abuse so real victim
mocked man fake victim praised
she faked being abused from Johnny Depp
dead butting her
of giving her a headbutt and uh
breaking her nose
but um
there was
there was no blood
there was no I I didn't hit her nose and
she came back about seven or eight
minutes later
she had a Kleenex
or of tissue to her nose
and um
and she then she pulled it away from her
nose and she showed it to me
look at her reaction red it was indeed
like red color on the
on the tissue she took it away and she
showed it to me she said way to go
Johnny you broke my nose
you broke my nose and then I pulled the
kleenex out of the
out of the trash bin
and I inspected it pretty closely
and realized that it was nail polish
there's no varnish or polish and then
she took another poop in my bed yes it
was great on both sides now I know
that's just him saying it I get that the
other but the other issues that we've
addressed there's evidence that's her
admitting it but her I wonder why she's
crying is she crying because she's
trying to keep up appearances and play a
victim or she crying because she
realizes like you were saying it's done
for you now there's no more victim card
well she's a shitty actress so the tears
are rich that's true yeah
but she is the reason that people are
looking forward to Aquaman too yes
there's a two I hope I can't believe
there was a one yeah it's the stupidest
superhero ever oh you talk to fish great
they use it on Entourage because they
were like no one's ever gonna actually
make this right yeah we're safe we'd
have to worry about the licensing rights
to the most useless superhero ever yeah
next up Aquaman and Medellin the Aquaman
Jaws crossover metaverse that's the only
place he's relevant oh
awful deep blue Mamoa now uh so here's
another fact for you um uh this is what
where we are now due to the uh I guess
maligning due to the allegations from
Amber Heard which keep in mind the
allegations that she made these in
Washington Post after they settled out
of court right so they were completely
unsubstantiated to be clear she never
had to prove or substantiate anything
that's why I'm telling you there is no
evidence because she never presented any
she wrote an op-ed in Washington Post
and and to defend his name and for his
kid for his his uh I think he has does
he have several kids yes he has several
kids I know he's got a daughter yeah
sure because she's in the movies with
him yeah no he has a son too does he
have a son as well yeah for his kid's
sake he needs to clear his name and he
needs to open up his private life to
everyone hey everyone out there if you
were if you've been in a relationship
would you want to have to reveal that to
everybody yeah people say ugly things
people do ugly things but he has to do
this he has to make sure that every
single bad thing he's done in his life
gets put under a microscope because she
wrote an op-ed
even though she decided to have her cake
and eat it too and write an article in
the Washington Post after she settled
she settled because she knew she
couldn't prove it
she got her leverage she got her money
and I said you know what but I'll also
claim abuse so due to that Johnny Depp's
career was was was ruined did you
experience any consequences after the
release of the op-ed
you know we absolutely and what were
those
oh I will
I believe it was uh I
don't think it took
Disney very long maybe a couple of days
to
announce that uh
that that I had been
removed from the Pirates of the
Caribbean
films franchise
well if only Johnny Depp had been
banging kids instead of getting abused
by women they probably would have given
him a new franchise yes that's the the
butt pirates of the Bay Area yes
very big
the Peter Pan version yes
but Pirates of Neverland I never want to
grow up great good we're on the same
page yes secret so we never get old
kinda there's Graves as long as you lost
boys stay lost and boys bang rang so
yeah oh gosh it's so terrible
um here's uh the the truth this is much
more common than reported in the media
and this is something that affects a lot
of men out there Johnny Depp is not you
know when people would say me too
meaning this isn't an isolated incident
and I understand that and I think that
this is why I want women to carry
firearms I want to hey by the way is it
waltherarms.com a sponsor we just did it
uh early on in the page is it Walther
arms.com Walther fire make sure if
someone can let me know the website
because uh uh Walter is a wonderful
sponsor to the show you can't go and buy
it uh on the website Walter arms but uh
you can't go and buy accessories and I
do recommend you go to your local gun
store just try it that's always what I
tell you Google Walther PDP review
Google
what because I got it wrong ah well I
got it right for anything else this is
why I want more women to carry firearms
and this is why I carry a Walther
everyone here does they're incredibly
reliable they're a great company they
have the balls to support this show I
want to see more headlines that read
woman shoots would be rapist than woman
raped and left in a ditch right yeah
it's very different from Aziz I'm sorry
having a bad date okay so do consider
just go go to your shop and just try the
Walther that's all that just try it see
if you don't give it a whale
um but this is far more common
Than People realize for the same reason
I think that we need to prosecute
rapists and I don't believe in Catch and
Release policy I believe in harsh
punishments for criminals uh I also
think that we need to punish
people who abuse the legal system
far more harshly now here's the thing
just like Amber Heard was not fearing
any
retribution for punching him in the face
for throwing a glass bottle at him
because she you know is under this
Unwritten agreement that men will not
fight back uh she also fears no
retribution of the legal system because
we have a court system as it relates to
marriage that very much unfairly favors
women at this point there was a reason
for at one point in time
and I say this it's very difficult
for me as a Christian who values the
institution of of marriage sometimes to
also make that sell to young men because
there's a difference between what we
believe to be marriage a holy Union a
matrimony and how the state has screwed
it up so first people may not know this
women are actually more often
domestic abusers than men wow so in 2020
there were 248
000 instances involving a female
perpetrator that's insane I had no idea
248 000 more than men only 225 000
involving a male perpetrator and by the
way what's also important to note is
that Amber Heard was arrested for
assaulting her ex-wife in an airport
spent the night in jail so she's
actually been guilty of this in the past
and here's the thing obviously the
statistics show this but it's very
underreported I guarantee you it's worse
I don't know a guy who hasn't been hit
by I mean look I've been in a
relationship where I was slapped around
Gerald a former girls that I dated you
know pushed me around a little not my
wife yeah exactly come on Tim I mean
yeah every one of us we don't we just
don't do anything about it she'll have
hands there control room get come on
yeah at some points guys yeah
Dave I had it coming yeah you said that
uh you had a girl a lot of girls yeah
she was trying to uh hook up with me in
the back of my friend's country kept
biting me and I was trying to get stop
but I couldn't put my hand it was creepy
I'm like stop biting my lip right yeah
no I don't know a single thing no I've
been I have been slapped I've been and
not even for doing anything bad right
this is something that but uh yeah uh I
was sucker punched in college by my
girlfriend out of the blue really even
looking at her and and Megan I Miss You
by the way well wait come on now let's
have some self-respect so this is this
is exactly something that a lot of
people when we were doing the run
through for this show yeah we realized
that um this this has happened to almost
every male that I have known has been uh
has been yeah yeah I uh hashtag me too I
uh I was violated in the face yeah oh
wow okay all right that's uh thank you I
appreciate I didn't I wasn't a call to
everyone in the control room
yeah you know that's enough that's
enough we get the point you know that we
get the clown we get the point yeah you
guys can get it clown deserved it I
think yeah had it coming
so this is something a lot of people
don't know women far more often commit
domestic abuse uh here's something else
the court system of course almost
automatically grants custody to a mother
we know that yeah single mothers more
often abusive toward children than
single fathers
talking numbers in 2020 221
000 instances involving only the mother
138
000 instances involving only the father
that's almost a difference of a hundred
thousand wow
think about that I don't think anybody
knew I would be very surprised if people
watching right now knew that all
references are available at lotto's
crowder.com and you know who does a
great job of this is Karen strong I
think it's uh I think it's own your [ __ ]
is her website we'll make sure that we
have it up we've had her on the show uh
just go run uh a search on unmug Club
YouTube probably won't show it with uh
you know a lot of crowder Karen strong
she was the one who really sort of did
the Deep dive into these statistics so
you have women more often commit
domestic abuse and relationships against
men that's a fact
do you think that that's reflected in
society
you have the effect that um women far
more often commit abuse against children
then do the fathers do you think that's
reflected in the custody system do you
think that's reflected in the court
system so now we have two examples of
women it's right or in movies you see
it's like an abusive father I don't I
don't see a whole lot of abusive and
remember how I said that Amber Heard
abused her ex-lover her lesbian lover
well as you said ex-wife I thought we
misspoke it no no no no her ex-wife well
yeah she swings both ways I had no idea
I should have mentioned that it almost
feels like it's Lloyd to get his money
almost feels like that yeah she's just
so lesbian couples have the highest
domestic abuse rate of almost any
demographic you know how scary that is
with steel toe boots yeah yes and not to
mention I mean like you know you're
wearing that plaid shirt from Orvis they
can get a good grip oh yeah collar
chokes oh
it's like hockey fight yeah it's like a
noose that's what it is they're just
they're just they're just pulling your
baggy baseball tee over your buzz cut
and just just grabbing the back of a
mullet yeah
who did your wife most look up to Bob
Probert well okay that makes sense it's
just like her
according to the National Coalition of
domestic violence
43.8 percent of lesbian women and 61.1
percent of bisexual women have
experienced rape fiscal violence or
stalking by an intimate partner and
these numbers are off the charts in
comparison to gay couples and comparison
so in other words if you have a
hierarchy you have gay couples the least
amount of domestic abuse yeah
heterosexual couples right in the middle
there lesbian couples
wow you go wait what is it what's the
common denominator there okay two women
now we take that let's slide it over is
it oh they commit more domestic violence
against men in heterosexual couples they
commit more violent abuse against
children so you start to see a pattern
here and I don't believe that it's
because all women
are inherently more violent but I do
believe that you have a lot of awful
women like Amber Heard right now who
just like we talked about uh Ezra Miller
think about this for a second just like
Johnny Depp has lost his career Ezra
Miller what 10 police calls on the
period of a year whatever the hell it
was he's he gets off scot-free why
because he's gay that's one of the
ultimate victim classes so you get away
with murder too many women feel as
though they can get away with this and
by the way you know who this affects
most not just men
but women out there because I I think
there's a statistic recently if someone
can get it from the control room I'm
going by wrote something like 40 40 of
men I don't know if it was in the United
States or a global study a startling
amount of young men have no interest in
getting married at all anymore and
that's not a good thing for women no no
it's not a good thing for the family
unit this ultimately also harms women
when neither party is held accountable
in a truthful way
boy body end up with some problems and
that's what this is about with Johnny
Depp it's about the systemic abuse
of a man uh in a in an abusive
relationship and it played out in the
public sphere where no journalists did
their due diligence because they wanted
to go out with a narrative regardless of
who it harms just like it's not any
different than black lives matter black
lives matter okay go with that narrative
who cares that there are billions of
dollars in Damages who cares that there
are dozens of murders and deaths and
thousands of casualties and businesses
uh that will never be repaired because
black lives matter hashtag me too who
cares that thousands of lives have been
ruined and who cares that men haven't
been believed when they come forward
with allegations of of of being actually
assaulted and they could substantiate it
ah you're a big guy you can take it
don't be a baby I'm about to [ __ ] on
your bed this is is the kind of stuff
that some guys have to deal with yeah
yeah are the real women like Rose
McGowan have been looked at like they're
crazy when it's like no that's obviously
somebody who's had to deal with an
actual right sexual assault right and it
all depends on your political persuasion
the color of your skin and if you have a
penis unless you're trans that's not the
way the justice system should work and
uh we were talking about this there does
need to be you know I believe marriage
is important but for sure I also think
that you have no fault divorce what does
that mean it means it's always the fault
of the person who's the provider here's
the thing if two people go into a couple
a relationship because you have it both
ways right this is another example if
you're both work no one should have an
issue with the prenuptial agreement no
but what often happens is oh you don't
trust me that's what Amber Heard said
when he wanted a post-nuptial agreement
because she started acting crazy she
said you don't trust me well a no and B
right you're a strong woman you're
making your own living why should you
care so a prenuptial agreement would
make sense if you're getting married if
you both work and if not okay well then
there's we now have an agreement where
it's the only agreement right now that I
know of in the United States a marital
agreement particularly if you have a man
who works in a woman who doesn't or a
man who earns more or vice versa where
one party is financially incentivized to
break it
and the only reason that you assume they
don't is because they're doing it for
love it's too easy to fake yeah well the
numbers in America right now show that
that's too easy to fix too many people
are getting married for the wrong
reasons but you and I when we were
talking about it it so the church having
marriage obviously we've believed in
that for a long time and I still believe
in that I think the church can do that
I've performed a wedding ceremony before
I didn't have to go get licensing
through the state I was registered
through the church the church obviously
sent that information off to the state
and said hey this guy is allowed to do
this but then they take that information
to the state to register and say hey
we're married and we're now a couple so
many people so many states can screw
this up we've talked about this with
just about every single thing possible
education taxes whatever you want to do
states can really mess things up and so
why would you say oh the state's going
to take care of this in a way that's
Equitable for people right State's going
to take care of this in a way that is
good for people as a a Christian man I
don't ever want to hear about a prenup
when I'm going to get married because I
should only be getting married if I am
100 certain that this is what I'm
supposed to be doing there can be
exceptions to that I totally understand
that I make room for that but so many
people get married today because they're
like oh it's just the next thing to do
we're just going to get married and it's
like you should have never been dating
right the hell are you doing getting
married yeah but then the state comes in
and that's where it gets very very messy
and honestly better better suggest what
do you think if if guys if every single
marriage came with a prenuptial
agreement kind of as the standard you
would actually have to sign a document
saying I don't want that that'd probably
be a better situation for people because
then at least you understand the rules
of the game yep you know and I think I
don't know you have States right now you
have States right now where a woman
could cheat on a man can marry a woman
who's never worked can marry a man cheat
on a man leave and take half there's a
gold digger that is the reason but guys
can do the same thing we're just not
we're less likely to do it we don't we
can't shake our tush and get a woman to
fall in love with us right it's a little
different some tushes are better than
others I get a day of yours it's uh
standing it's pretty good sometimes I
find it difficult to not bite your lip
myself but when I feel that urge I just
quell it and take a poop in your bed
that's what you do
I'm a bed pooper pooper I can't believe
she took a dump in his I can this is a
horrible person no again
that's Disney money when you're like
I'll just give her seven million dollars
to leave Hitler's like oh that that's a
bit over the line yeah that's cruel oh
why would you do that that's true that
doesn't make any sense no don't don't
shits in any exhibits come on come on
don't [ __ ] in the bed she found seven
million dollars but for rum diaries this
is not right you're destroying this man
it is it's a think of the and I also
think it's important think of the fear
that he was living in does this and this
is something else too you see this a lot
does this seem like a woman who's afraid
who's being battered and abused when you
listen to those calls if you're afraid
of a man hitting you and breaking your
nose do you take a crap in his bed right
do you poke the bear but look this
wasn't hard to find this has been around
for years at this point and places like
varieties still say oh privileged white
male oh look at how they're being
pampered oh poor Johnny Depp at what
point do we do we actually use the term
of victim blaming this guy and I'm not
even a giant fan so I know they're gonna
be a bunch of Johnny Depp fans coming
over here on YouTube because it's almost
the Michael Jackson fans I hope that you
appreciate that I have not liked a
Johnny Depp film since I believe Don
Juan DeMarco to a movie yeah Pirates one
no no no no but I I my heart breaks for
the guy and I just hope that there is a
backlash Amber Heard gets everything she
deserves yes and I don't think she will
I I hope she does I hope it's
financially very difficult because you
can't you can't be allowed to go out and
do this kind of thing because you'll
incentivize the next person if there are
no consequences to this you're basically
playing the lottery yeah and also men
you need to come forward you need to
come forward if you're being uh
physically abused more men need to do
that we need to break that and I get it
it's it is it's silly it's real it's
silly because yeah it doesn't hurt you
as bad physically I get it but it's a
symptom of the actual abuse that you're
experiencing and there needs to be uh
there needs to be more accountability on
both sides and the accountability needs
to the north star of all of us needs to
be truth and we are so far off the beam
right now that we are seeing we're
seeing the destruction of the
institution of marriage and it's not
because of two guys and chokers in San
Francisco even though it doesn't help
now well men are also stupid and allow
this to happen in a lot of ways because
we we also you know White Knight
ourselves right because anytime there's
a woman who can even like act like she's
in distress go to a think about a bar in
your 20s where you don't know the
situation and a girl's screaming at a
guy it's like can I help you you know
what happened right like guys involve
themselves inside with the woman so
easily that we they've been trained over
years to believe like well I'm hot and I
can get away with anything and I can get
any guy to stand up for me at any time
yeah and it's our own stupidity that has
caused that I mean that's true we think
with our dicks and that's a huge problem
in society I well what that's true
that's true very true yes but it is a
huge we do it to ourselves well
sometimes it's a micro problem it's a
bigger problems people who walk off the
show
but the principle is the same I don't
mean to be crass no you're absolutely
you're absolutely uh you're absolutely
right but I think it's the same with you
know the guys who are writing the
articles that are like this will get
women to like me right yeah exactly it's
the same dude you're white knighting
yourself it's like Bill Burr has that
pit where he's like you know watching
over step there's never ever a reason to
hit a woman I could think of like 19 off
the top of my head
and a drunken stupid
are you like seven
dude there's never a reason to hit a
woman there are plenty of reasons you
just don't do it yeah
that's a great point you just don't
that's exactly what it is she threw a
bottle at your hand uh breaking it
cutting to the Bone and giving you MRSA
don't you dare start throwing hands
she can throw full bottles of alcohol
all right only a coward hits back yeah
she's stabbing me yeah and calling me a
coward for not doing anything oh baby oh
what a baby just taking it aren't you
why don't you do anything
silly thing like think of how many times
Humphrey Bogart those guys back in the
day like the woman he's like no stop
they just grab the rest like no stop it
honey yeah yeah I mean now we're now
restraining because when she was saying
you had buttered her he was restraining
her while she was assaulting him now
they want to accuse men restraining of
violent women of the assault that
they're committing and I don't agree
with that at all I don't agree with that
at all I think you absolutely have the
right to restrain a woman who's
attacking you I'm sorry your wrists are
bruised you were trying to punch in the
nose yeah I'm just trying to get you to
stop throwing handles of vodka yeah I'm
sorry you're slightly winded from my
bear hug
you're trying to stab me in the neck
repeatedly Good Fellas sorry I shut the
door hard
meanwhile she could be kicking him like
Robert De Niro and casino
I guess I'll just sit here and take it
here's something else while we're
talking about this uh and smash that
like button if you're watching on
YouTube that helps again with the
algorithm and uh again let us know if uh
if you don't want the Ash Wednesday with
half asian lawyer Bill Richmond no we
have to comment below and if you want it
you have to let us know otherwise we're
not going to do it we have to
he has some pretty good insight into
this contractually obligated so here's
something else another story that we
need to hit uh
there is um uh a college I'm trying to
think about a frame this because I don't
want this to be crass but this is
reality just keep in mind that there's a
difference between uh engaging in
depravity and showing you what's taking
place and don't worry we're not going to
show you anything pornographic
Westminster College in Salt Lake City
which surprised that surprises Mormons
and porn don't usually go together no
I'm surprised have you seen Mormon
pornography it's very boring is this the
dog show
no that's John O'Hurley
pornography is also bordering on
unwatchable
well I tell you I'm very much enjoying
this penetration yes so my favorite so
far yes as I wear my sombrero Urban hat
a sound class
um Salt Lake City Utah Westminster
College they're now offering a course in
watching pornography uh here you go
according to that class description
online it says that they will watch more
together to talk about the sexualization
from race to also gender and class which
has drawn in some curiosity watch and
some criticism
students pursue higher education to
learn I really don't think that it's
that big of a deal but this class at
Western of course you know with a
Direct's name porn has drawn in the
question of whether this is appropriate
in higher education I feel like a lot of
my friends are super sex positive and we
talk about this stuff all the time first
zero people are surprised that that guy
answered that way yeah second every boy
in that class is just looking around at
the women's reactions like I don't even
know yeah
I love her response my friends are sex
positive and what what does that even
mean so the best grade you can get is
two D's yes
this is the dumbest thing I also don't
know how bra sizes work because there
are numbers and then there are also
letters yeah I don't fully understand it
don't get derailed on that oh well
it's very easy to get derails just love
that if one has to get derailed by the
way do they need to offer a class on
this in college I kind of thought that
well they said hardcore pornography is
as American as apple pie no no it's not
uh it's more more as German as strudel
they're kind of a they're kind of at The
Cutting Edge I didn't realize that in
college I had been doing so much
homework right
and more popular than Sunday Night
Football they've just got a doctor in
the course students will watch
pornographic films together and discuss
the sexualization of race class and
gender here's the thing look
I'm anti-pornography just to be clear
yes uh I and and people can be
anti-pornography and still feel the pull
of pornography and have struggled with
every single man in 2022 has had an
issue with pornography in one fashion or
another if you've ever used a web
browser okay and there are resources we
had a great uh guest on your brain on
porn so I just want to be clear about
that that being said
race class gender in pornography
you can't cheat the penis okay it's a
veritable Beauty weather stick the only
SEC the only the only case to be made is
that people of certain races are being
sexualized because certain men want to
have sex with them
gender because people like watching
typically members of the opposite sex
gender interchangeable uh have sex class
I don't know I haven't seen many
pornography films where they come out
with their pay stub well it's there well
chances are if you're I already assume
if you're in porn you're not doing well
well I bet I mean as far as it being
projected I mean I guess if they mean
you know for example they one always
takes advantage of the pizza boy he's
probably earning minimum wage but he
works for tips we had Pretty Woman you
know the last structure we could yeah I
don't feel the owl but same kind of
thing I don't feel the sticky girl
looking into the camera saying the name
of the company yeah exactly doing well
yeah like yeah yeah oh I'm really glad
that I just uh had sex with all those
people here are some stock tips yeah
there's yeah let's see this have you
heard of uh have you heard of ethereum
no this doesn't happen no the point is
it's a stupid class surprise for my bit
it's Bitcoin YouTube page
it's a stupid class as a dumb Professor
it's a silly school for doing it but uh
between yesterday afternoon and this
morning the school actually removed the
exact uh course offering from the
website so this is the good news this is
now this happened in a college but these
types of things also happen in high
school thanks to people like lives of
tick tock thanks to you sending your
tips to tips that a lot of crowded.com
where you guys send us tips and teachers
are then uh showcased
and parents get involved right where
people say this is absurd so you can
make a difference this one happened
really quickly and just to clarify uh I
do not believe that uh hardcore
pornography is a legitimate course to
study also I don't know some people just
some people will disagree with me
they'll say sex work is real work no
it's not YouTube we're about to go to
Thursday mug Club chat my favorite day
YouTube piss off
foreign
[Music]